in our studio right now is Donald J
Trump Thank You Howard great to see
senator Sanders thank you thank you
thank you for the title Howard it's good
to be here
senator sir are you okay yeah I'm great
I'll go to you first mr. Trump what will
you do about Isis we have a terrible
problem with Isis they're everywhere and
we need to stop these young Muslim men
from coming in there
Isis is and everywhere near in there in
Italy Isis is in Italy okay and they're
called Italian Isis and mr. Trump your
Butler recently talked to the New York
Times yeah he said when you're in a sour
mood
do you play hail to the chief wrong
Melania does hail to the qwave and she
queefs out the entire thing senator
Sanders what were the first 100 days in
office look like for you my first 100
days would be an epic party day one the
drum circle begins in the first week we
would coat the White House in patchouli
oil and within the first month I would
Institute a national bike path that goes
from Portland to Portland and back to
Portland and finally I think the
crowning achievement of my first 100
days in office will be a national
Netflix account with one shared password
so we are no longer burdening our
seniors or our nephews for the Netflix
password yes I am talking about single
player Netflix and we could do it in our
lifetime mr. Trump Michelle Obama one to
ten I would say a six I think Jesus six
it's the arms that take her out let's go
to Taylor Swift is she too flat she's
too flat and she can't keep a man our
God I wonder what's going on their show
I have to say I'm very worried about her
and if I could talk to her and creep my
hand up her thigh until we do a live
fingering I'd say a seven what would you
do to robin sexually my angle man i
would turn robin and said uh i would
start with the breasts right and i would
push them up against her cheeks you know
Robin had breast reduction wait I'm
against it what do you think of that I
think get a back brace Jesse it is so
great to see you yeah well it's good to
be back I've been waiting in Mexico for
your phone call let me lay out my theory
on 911 for you because we've danced
around it a few times on the show Howard
right I believe that the first hour
was a conspiracy go ahead and that the
second tower came down according to the
official story Wow
why don't you come down and visit me
sometime Howard I'm afraid of you why
would you be afraid of me I live in a
Cabana I pursue the path of peace I'm a
peaceful warrior